[Música]
la asamblea nacional de Ecuador aprobó
un informe en el que se recomienda un
juicio político contra el presidente
Guillermo lasso el texto había sido
emitido la semana pasada por parte de
una comisión que investiga una presunta
corrupción en círculos cercanos al
mandatario
el tráfico de armas de fuego entre
Estados Unidos y Haití está
multiplicando la violencia en la nación
caribeña así lo reveló un informe de
Naciones Unidas que denuncia que este
tipo de armamento está cayendo en manos
de las pandillas que intentan controlar
al país
el expresidente jael bolsonaro dijo que
su misión presidencial no ha terminado
el mandatario intervino en un evento de
políticos conservadores en Estados
Unidos donde se encuentra desde
principios de año y del que también
participó el ex presidente Donald Trump
Hola Bienvenidos a las noticias del
continente americano en France 24 los
saluda Andrés Meza Muñoz empezamos en
Ecuador el pleno de la asamblea nacional
aprobó el informe de una comisión que
recomienda llevar a juicio político al
presidente Guillermo lasso el texto
surgió de las investigaciones por el
denominado caso encuentro que indaga una
presunta trama de corrupción relacionada
con empresas públicas los detalles de
esta noticia con nuestro corresponsal en
Quito Gustavo Ortega la asamblea
nacional aprobó el informe que
recomienda el juicio político en contra
del presidente Guillermo lasso un
informe que no es vinculante que es el
preámbulo de un largo proceso que podría
durar casi dos meses en ver la luz en el
parlamento ecuatoriano a partir de este
momento comenzará formalmente con una
solicitud de juicio político desde el
parlamento pasará por la corte
constitucional y de ser aprobado volverá
a la asamblea para un eventual debate en
el pleno del parlamento O podría ser
archivado Guillermo lasso podrá
defenderse ante el pleno de la asamblea
nacional pero la aprobación del pleno no
ha tardaron en generar reacciones el
propio presidente de la república y
suministro de gobierno Guillermo lasso
ha ordenado a todas las funciones
ejecutivo Que responda con transparencia
a las investigaciones en su contra que
requiera la fiscalía general del estado
para llegar a fin a este caso en
Colombia está ha sido una semana
complicada para el presidente Gustavo
Petro una crisis ministerial protestas
campesinas y el inicio de una
investigación por parte de la fiscalía
contra uno de sus hijos todo esto cuando
la ONU se mostró preocupada por el
aumento de violencia en 2022 más
detalles con lluís Muñoz
una semana difícil para Gustavo Petro el
presidente de Colombia empezó el lunes
con la destitución de tres ministros por
desacuerdos ante la reforma a la salud
que propone y la terminó con un
conflicto en San Vicente del caguán en
el Sureño departamento del caquetá
antiguo bastión de las FARC Campesinos
de la zona llevaban protestando un mes
exigiendo que la petrolera emeral Energy
cumpliese con su promesa de pavimentar
42 kilómetros de vía el jueves escaldó
la situación murieron un líder campesino
y un policía 79 uniformados y seis
trabajadores fueron retenidos hasta ser
liberados el viernes tras la promesa de
Petro de visitar la zona y encontrar una
solución es un gesto
que debe llevar a un replanteamiento de
muchos temas alrededor de el tratamiento
del conflicto social en Colombia también
el viernes se hizo público el informe
anual del alto comisionado para los
derechos humanos en 2022 se registró Un
aumento de la violencia especialmente en
el asesinato de líderes y masacres pero
desde la ONU se muestran esperanzados en
las futuras reformas hemos visto de la
violencia de los grupos armados en los
territorios y por eso llamamos tanto a
la política de desmantelamiento porque
son los grupos armados no estatales y
las organizaciones criminales quienes
están generando tanta violencia en los
territorios
el alto comisionado para la paz de
Colombia destacó el descenso de los
homicidios en enero de 2023 resultados
que Petro relaciona con su proyecto de
paz total con el que busca el fin del
conflicto después de seis décadas este
proceso ha sido otro de sus dolores de
cabeza esta semana el jueves el
presidente pidió a la fiscalía que
Investiga su hijo y a su hermano por
supuestamente haber recibido dinero a
cambio de beneficios presidenciales y
judiciales para paramilitares y
narcotraficantes prácticas de las que
petros se ha desmarcado desde Estados
Unidos el expresidente Jair bolsonaro
dijo que su misión presidencial no ha
terminado Pese a que dejó el poder hace
más de dos meses sus declaraciones se
dieron durante la conferencia política
de acción conservadora
un evento que se realizó en el estado de
Maryland y que también y del que también
participó el expresidente Donald Trump
hace unas semanas bolsonaro dijo que
pronto volverá a Brasil para hacer
oposición al gobierno de su sucesor Luis
Ignacio Lula da Silva
en esta tierra me siento como si
estuviera en Brasil tierra de libertad
progreso y orden es lo que muchos
políticos dicen fácilmente pero no lo
creen no es fácil ser un político
Especialmente cuando quieres honrar tu
mundo tus palabras y ayudar a la gente
en este momento doy gracias a Dios por
mi segunda vida y también por la misión
de ser el presidente de Brasil por un
periodo pero siento en el fondo que esta
misión no ha terminado la oficina de
Naciones Unidas contra la droga y el
delito publicó su más reciente informe
sobre la situación de seguridad en Haití
el documento concluye que una de las
principales causas de la violencia de
las pandillas en el país es el tráfico
ilegal de armas provenientes en su
mayoría de Estados Unidos informe de
Samuel Salgado
escenas de caos en Puerto Príncipe
ciudadanos de la capital haitiana huyen
del enfrentamiento armado entre la
policía y las pandillas que intentan
tomar el control de estas calles con
fronteras invisibles
disparos continuos desde hace una semana
han aterrorizado los residentes de
algunos distritos como 18 y 24 y Chris
obligándolos a abandonar sus casas
Hay que dormir en la calle volví esta
mañana y veo que las cosas siguen igual
no tengo a dónde ir no tengo a dónde ir
según el más reciente informe sobre
Haití en la oficina de las Naciones
Unidas contra la droga y el delito el
creciente tráfico ilegal de armas de
fuego y de drogas agudizan los problemas
de seguridad del país la cifra de
homicidios registrada en 2019 se duplicó
en 2022 llegando a más de 2000 muertes
violentas en un solo año Mientras que el
secuestro modalidad bastante utilizada
por las pandillas aumentó más de 16
veces en 2022 Comparado con 2019 ambos
gráficos demuestran que la situación
humanitaria y la inestabilidad social y
política empeoraron desde el magnicidio
el presidente
en julio de 2021
otro punto clave preocupa a la comunidad
internacional en este informe la
transnacionalización del crimen las
armas que entran Haití provienen en su
mayoría de Estados Unidos y hacen su
tránsito por República Dominicana país
fronterizo con Haití el fácil tráfico de
armas se debe a la incompetencia de las
autoridades haitianas en el control de
las fronteras y a la gran cantidad de
importaciones que recibe el país por los
puertos marítimos terrestres y aéreos
debido a la dependencia de ayuda
humanitaria
vamos hacia Estados Unidos y más
precisamente al estado de California que
acaba de vivir una ola de frío y de
Nevadas bastante inavit para esta región
del país los expertos ya señalan que se
podría tratar de nuevas manifestaciones
de la crisis climática
este hombre llevaba 48 horas encerrado
en su casa
su Vivienda Está rodeada de increíbles
muros de nieve con equilibrio inestable
si bien se trata de una región montañosa
estos pueblos californianos no habían
visto un fenómeno semejante desde hace
40 años no tenemos a dónde ir la nieve
me llega por encima de los hombros están
alrededor de toda la casa empezó hace ya
siete días ahora se está poniendo muy
difícil
ayúdenos han escrito los habitantes de
chrisline en la nieve mientras sigue la
ayuda lo urgente es limpiar los tejados
si Calcula que en promedio hay de 500 a
600 kilogramos de nieve por metro
cuadrado esto es demasiado para los
marcos de algunas casas ni siquiera el
supermercado resistió se organizan
distribuciones de alimentos en la calle
y hay muchas personas familias aisladas
que ya no tenían nada de comer en sus
casas el sol vuelve la ayuda se organiza
poco a poco algunas familias atrapadas
por fin son rescatadas
no sé cómo agradecerles estamos tan
aliviados tan felices de volver a la
vida normal me siento tan abrumada a
veces hay nevadas en el Sur de
California pero nunca tan fuertes ni
durante tanto tiempo
Es difícil entender la magnitud de este
fenómeno para nosotros que estamos en el
Sur de California
muchos científicos atribuían estas
nevadas sin precedente a la crisis
climática en Estados Unidos estos
fenómenos extremos son noticia todos los
días nieve en California huracán en
Texas este Tornado filmado ayer es el
número 180 en tres meses los daños son
diarios todas las regiones del país
están ahora en alerta
hasta que es informativo Gracias por
acompañarnos
[Música]